- [Narrator] Nothing
says Britain more than...
Nope.
Keep going.
Ah, yes, there it is.
A nice cup of tea.
(bright music)
We know we have China to thank
for introducing tea to the Western world.
But how did it make its way to England
and become the cultural
obsession it is today?
Well, that's all thanks
to one Portuguese woman.
The year, 1662.
The person, Catherine of Braganza.
She had just won the hand
of England's King Charles II
with the help of a very large dowry
including money, treasures, and spices.
This worthwhile trade made her
the Queen of England,
Scotland, and Ireland.
When she arrived to her new homeland,
she brought with her
packets of loose leaf tea
in crates labeled Transporte
de Ervas Aromaticas.
It's a theory that this was
later abbreviated to T-E-A, tea.
Now tea could already be found in England
but was only really used
for medicinal purposes.
Catherine continued drinking
tea to her heart's content.
- Mm.
- [Narrator] And as the new
royal, everything about her,
including her beverage habits,
was copied by other ladies desperate
to be just like their idol.
Another thing Catherine
brought to the table
from Portugal was the idea
of tea drinking experience.
She popularized the use of
porcelain teacups and mugs.
By the end of the 17th century,
much of British aristocracy
were enjoying the hot beverage.
- [Woman] Oo, delightful.
- [Narrator] And soon
enough, so was everyone else.
Today, while tea can be
found pretty much everywhere,
it remains a special daily
pastime for the Brits.
- Mm.
- [Narrator] So carry on and
drink tea, people of England.